-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy- and Golden Globe-winning
actor you know from his work
in "The Big Lebowski,"
"The Artist,"
and "The Righteous Gemstones."
He stars in "The Conners," which
returns January 13th on ABC.
Please welcome back to the sho
our very good friend
John Goodman.
John, how are you?
-Swell! How you doing, Seth?
Happy new year.
-Happy new year to you.
I feel like this is the closes
our haircuts have ever been.
-Pretty much.
I got a COVID-19 cut.
-Yeah, same here. Same here.
I know were you in New Orleans
for a long time.
You're back in L.A.
shooting "The Conners" now
How was your time
in New Orleans?
-It was great.
[ Chuckles ]
I didn't want to leave.
The streets were a little
emptier than usual,
but it was good to be home
-You know, obviously,
New Orleans known for
its live music scene.
Live music clubs are getting
hit hard, very hard.
You did a fundraiser
on New Year's Eve.
How do you feel about thos
live music venues?
And do you have some favorites
in New Orleans?
-Yeah, I do, but it's...
Yeah, they're really
getting whacked,
and it's been that way
for a long time.
I met my wife at Tipitina'
in like 1988.
And she kind of thought
I was a zombie,
so I had a buddy of mine
keep track of her,
and we started dating
a year later.
Yeah, I kind of stalked her,
real long-distance.
-[ Laughs ] But it's worked out,
obviously.
-So far! 31 years.
-You guys are back
doing "The Conners."
It's a show that's filmed
in front of a live
studio audience.
You don't have one,
I'm assuming.
-Not anymore.
We get a lot more done.
[ Laughs ]
No, we shoot it differently now.
Those guys will laugh
at anything,
and it's kind of hard
to time things sometimes.
-I remember going to a sho
in the studio audience.
Like, you really are sort of
whipped into a frenzy
by the warm-up comic,
which is their job
and they do
a very good job at it,
but I can imagine sometime
it messes with comic rhythm.
-Well, they're in this frenz
for hours, you see.
And I guess they like to hea
themselves on the playback
when they watch it at home
But, yeah, it's impossible
to time anything.
-Is it hard to generate
the same performance level
without an audience, or ar
you guys finding it's okay
-It's okay, but we really
got to think about it
and remember that that's
a whole nother energy leve
when you got people
in the audience.
-Yeah.
-Laughing at everything.
-We, of course,
first met at "SNL,"
which is a live studio audienc
that is not whipped
into a frenzy
in the same way
that a sitcom audience is.
I remember
Norm Macdonald once said
he thought it was the last
true audience in television,
because they're just --
you can just bomb on "SNL"
like nowhere else.
-Yeah, and it's weird
when you watch it --
when you're doing the show
and you watch it played back
because the studio audienc
is a lot louder
than they amplify it at home
So you could be doing alright,
but it sounds like you jus
murdered somebody.
-[ Laughs ]
"The Conners" is actually gonn
address the pandemic,
which is no surprise.
This is a show that has
addressed real-life issues
very modern issues,
things up to and including
even opioid addition --
Addiction. Excuse me.
Is it interesting
to be doing a show
that's sort of addressing issues
in real time?
-Yeah, sure, 'cause everybod
brings their two cents into it
things they've experienced
And, you know, why pretend
it's not there?
I personally would rather
have them let me solve crime
on the show.
-[ Laughs ] You should.
Have you ever solved
a crime on a show?
-I'd like to.
I'd like to start doing that
And at home, as well.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I feel like if you solved
a couple crimes
on your own at home,
then they'd spin it
into a TV show immediately
-If I talk to some guys
about it first.
You know, kick the interest up
-You were one of my favorite
shows from --
I guess now two years ago.
That's how time is moving.
"The Righteous Gemstones."
I know you guys were going bac
to do a second season
that got sort of waylaid b
everything we're going through
That must be a fun show to do.
-Yeah, it's great.
Just every day is a lot of fun
Working with some
spectacular people,
and the situations are great
It's gonna be a doozy this yea
from what I'm reading.
But, yeah, we got there,
I got my clothes
out of the suitcase
and groceries in for the -
getting ready to start work,
and they canned us
for two months,
which turned into permanently.
-I love Danny McBride,
but Walton Goggins has bee
one of my long favorites.
And I will say, the feud
between the two of you
is just a delight to watch
-Yeah. He's terrific.
He's just incredibly funny
-Exciting news was announced
that you and Billy Crystal
are going to be the voices
for a "Monsters Inc."
television show.
That was a show that --
that movie, I should say,
came out so long ago.
Is it exciting
to come back to it?
-Yeah. It's a lot of fun.
I don't -- I haven't gotte
to work with Billy
in the same studio yet.
That really gooses the energy,
because he's
hard to keep up with.
-Your daughter was very youn
when the first "Monsters Inc."
came out.
As she grew up, what of your
work has she engaged with
and enjoyed the most?
-Ah, not really
any of them, so...
[ Laughter ]
-No? Not a Lebowski fan?
-Nah.
It's just,
"Dad's home again. Eh."
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, a lot of kids,
that's what they know me from.
That voice.
-And when they hear it,
do they...
Can you tell when
a kid hears your voice
and recognizes it from that?
-I know they recognize
something.
"Something's wrong
with this guy."
-I mean, there could be
any number of reasons
they react that there's
something wrong with you.
You realize that?
It might not just be
that they recognize your voice
from "Monsters Inc."
-It's the same vibe.
[ Laughter ]
There's just gradations of it.
You have to be aware of that
-I'm gonna let you go 'cause
I know you have some crime
to solve in the house.
-Thanks, Seth.
-John, it's always a delight
to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.